[Music]
let's people think that founding of the
American government is kind of crass
that it understands that people are
selfish
and it sets them off against each other
so that they can't hurt each other
and there's some color of truth to that
it means that if people are gonna be
self-governing and run the government
and hold the sovereignty they need to be
good people
well how does the Constitution help
produce such people it's an interesting
thing the purpose of the government of
the United States is to protect our
rights our freedom all of that that's
surely true and powerful but also it's
interested in our character in building
our character in helping us to be better
than George Washington claims speaking
words that were actually written by
James Madison his first inaugural that
if we become better people we will be
happier people you have to think for a
minute about these founders because
before they were founders of a political
system what did they do how did
Alexander Hamilton get to know George
Washington they don't they were warriors
they conquered right they signed the
document they put their name on the line
and they fought a war and they want it
and the implication in all of human
history is that now they're gonna get
the rule they're gonna be the kings and
the court there's a story and it might
not be true and it might be true there's
there's a evidence both ways which means
you don't know if it's true really
I would rue the day that anybody proved
that didn't happen and the story is that
the King George the 3rd could not be
brought to call the Peace Conference
after they had given up after the Battle
of Yorktown cuz you know my wife is
English and I adore her in her country
but we did really kick him pretty hard
there
[Laughter]
one of the minister says to the king
sorry we have to call a peace conference
he done lost the New World think of that
you understand by the way there can
never be another new world we know the
world now I have to go some other planet
I guess and the king he's got to be
thinking in that awesome we've got all
of that and then they lost it all he
said reportedly George Washington will
not know how to be a king they will want
me back you see the assumption he
conquered nice King that's how it works
right and the minister is reported to
have said I understand that he has
resigned his office and gone home and
the King said if that is true he's the
greatest man in the world but she was by
the way for that reason when you get all
that right then it emerges that you have
to set it up in some way so that it
won't collapse of its own weight who is
the chairman of the Constitutional
Convention and they needed him they
really needed him he was the name to
conjure with if they announced that
there was going to be a Constitutional
Convention that they are the kind the
Confederation Congress appointed or
called the convention if they announced
that he was going to be the chairman of
it then that's extremely reassuring
right and he almost didn't come and the
reason is he was a member of the Society
of Cincinnatus do you know what that is
Cincinnatus was a roman thing Tim you're
about to tell us well Cincinnatus like
kind of similar to George Washington was
called up as a he was just a farmer and
he was called a peasant general and he
went served and helped them win many
battles and conquer their enemies and
then when the war was over he just
returned to his farm quietly and this
this organization was
formed by veterans of the Revolutionary
War and George Washington was the head
of it but then it got attacked and the
press as being some kind of an
aristocratic thing and George Washington
was very sensitive about things like
that and so he declined to attend a big
meeting of the Society of the Cincinnati
and he said that he was indisposed he
didn't want to embarrass them but he
didn't want rumors that he was joining
an aristocratic Society then the
Constitutional Convention comes up and
he's going to attend that and he thinks
that'll make the Society of the
Cincinnati look bad I won't go to that
either and James Madison got on his
horse and rode several hours to Mount
Vernon and talked him into it because
James Madison knew how things worked you
know and and he did and that's why they
were able to build a strong executive so
now what does James Madison say is the
most important thing about the
Constitution and the chief way it will
protect our liberties he says it makes
ambition counteract ambition in order as
I say it is true that's very good how
does it do that
that's what I'm asking then he says he
puts reason instead of passion that's
true and very important and how does it
do that what feature of the Constitution
best achieves these things is this one
of the obvious answers like separation
of powers yeah which he says is the
structure of the Constitution in other
words there's no one provision it's the
whole thing
the structure is where because it will
channel the way we do politics to make
that way the results healthier the whole
structure right and the structure is
separation of powers that's how its laid
out and when he when he gets ready to
justify that that's where he talks about
the order of the human soul
which has to do with the arrangement of
rationality and passions it's worth
adding that Madison didn't think and the
great philosophers don't think that
passions are to be banished what you
want is terribly important and it's
terribly important that you want the
right thing and every choice you make is
a combination of thinking and desiring
and if you practice making choice as
well you will come not only to think
better about how to get the right thing
but you will want the right thing and so
the Constitution in its structure is
devised to engender the correct
cooperation between reason and passion
and that in your own lives you need to
do that very much need to do that a
little short lecture there are two kinds
of virtues in the greatest book in my
opinion ever written about ethics the
first book Aristotle's ethics and that
he says in there that there's two kind
of virtues doing virtues and thinking
virtues and that doing virtues have to
do with what you want the doing virtues
are three the prime ones their courage
and moderation and justice will take
courage and moderation courage has to do
with pain and moderation has to do with
pleasure and the virtue is the right
disposition toward those things you have
to want to do the brave thing if you
want to do what Aristotle says is the
beautiful thing the action that is
beautiful to behold if you want to do
that then you're courageous but if you
do it like charge the enemy when there's
no hope and no advantage to it then
you're a fool you're imprudent
and it's not really a beautiful act that
it means that it takes thinking - if -
you have to be able to figure out what
to do pleasure is the same way to
attempt to forego all pleasure would be
foolishness you'd be giving up
friendship
you starve yourself to death or
something right but we're talking about
here about a structure the channel's the
public control of the government in a
way that encourages good character in
the people and the person they pick to
be the chief executive is the person
everybody thought was the greatest
character
you
[Music]